you have become known as like the
beloved queen of viral memes on the
internet oh my god how aware are you of
that like like your birthday interview
went viral the limes went viral how
aware are you of those moments and do
you enjoy them i'm not aware of them you
turned 30. i did and um how was the
party i wasn't invited
actually no that's not the truth ellen
you were invited last year no last time
i was on the show last year
you gave me a bunch about not inviting
you but i didn't even know you wanted to
be invited well who didn't want to be
invited to a party well i didn't even
know you liked me
i don't know these things happen and
then like a year later somebody is
asking me about it actually the other
day spike jones sent me a picture of a
woman who works with him wearing a
t-shirt of something i said with a
drawing of me on it that looks like what
that's wild do you just laugh about it
yeah because i don't i'm not really on
social media i don't i don't see these
things so to me it's just
bizarre
sorry it's bizarre
dakota you know i have to ask you about
madame webb so many congratulations
thank you what can you tell us about
this project if anything because of
course it's very shrouded in mystery but
how excited are you and what do you
think the film will bring i can tell you
pretty much nothing that isn't already
on the internet i'm so excited it's
pretty cool to be in the marvel world
especially with a character that's not
so known there's a lot of space for us
to make her very cool and yeah i'm
really excited was it a dream of yours
to play a superhero at some point it's
always been a dream of mine to do
some kind of like massive
action movie like i always wanted to do
like a female indiana jones or like uh i
remember you telling me that yeah i
really have always like i saw the new
top gun and it's so good
oh my god
it's so good there's something about
those movies that you're just like wow a
real human being can do that yeah and
the cast is shaping up sydney sweeney is
joining how are you feeling about that
incredible cast and like have you seen
any scripts yet could you tell us that i
have yeah how are they looking
i can tell you nothing
i can't believe college is over you have
a job now we're not allowed to talk
about jobs at the bottom it's a party so
you either don't have a job or you have
a bad job how much does a party starter
get paid i wonder
i have a bad job so i have to give you
credit cooper because i learned a new
job in this movie i did not know that
party starting was a thing did you ever
really work as a party starter how did
this come about i didn't work as a party
starter but there was this guy named
vince i'm from dallas texas and i went
to a party and a service every saturday
when i was in seventh grade and there
was this guy named vince who worked all
of had we went to a small school and he
worked every single party and that's
that was my intro so what are you both
like at parties are you the party
starters or how do you both engage i
love to dance i'm not really i'm not
good like andre at getting people on to
the dance floor but i will
dance okay yeah sam okay you're the
party starter no i'm not i'm not a party
star but i like to dance cooper you have
two i don't know what to call them other
than maybe comedic geniuses playing your
parental figures in this movie brad
garrett and v leslie mann what was it
like to work with them and was that kind
of a dream come true moment honestly
everyone was a comedic genius like
dakota vanessa i love evan to death i
wouldn't say he's a community genius but
everyone was very very funny on set we
all had very shared senses of humor and
sensibilities and yeah it was really fun
to let like dakota and leslie and brad
say what they wanted to say a lot of
improv like was it hard to a lot of like
rewriting the lines right before like
dakota would say like so this this this
needs to change and so we would change
like go for it let's do it i love that
what did you want to add when you were
changing those lines this process was
different because we worked on
everything um we were always script
buddies
yeah also depending on what we shot and
how it went and if anything was
improvised or if we didn't get something
or we got extra whatever it was then we
would adjust further the following
scenes so that it would make more sense
or call back to a joke that was made
that wasn't previously in the script so
just like constantly updating so that it
was like a real cohesive story yeah was
that fun for you i would imagine that's
not always the case that you can work
and change up the script so much usually
people get
are annoyed with me because i want to do
that so i guess and i'm so grateful
i really am
i guess now because because it's my
movie it's you know
because i was a producer yeah that
nobody could tell me i couldn't do that
right even if you weren't a producer i
would have not been annoyed
like some people really do get annoyed
they're like you're just an actress how
could you know but like i have a brain
in my head
yeah
but yeah no cooper was super
collaborative and especially in that way
he
like me has the ability to learn lines
pretty quickly so we could rewrite a
whole scene beforehand and then wow and
then shoot it the characters in this
movie they do face the dilemma of
figuring out their futures what they're
going to do and we were curious if
either of you was not in acting have you
ever thought about what another future
could be like for you if you'd made a
big change at a younger age i think i'd
be a florist i always wanted to have
like a tiny little flower shop that also
made like the best cookie and the best
cup of coffee just it's like one stop
shop
in the morning when you're like going to
apologize to somebody
that's i love that story apology flower
that's what people
so you go and you get like really
gorgeous flowers
really chic gorgeous flowers and then
a cup of coffee and a cookie that's for
yourself really good
for yourself even though you're
apologizing but you're bringing a coffee
and a cookie to somebody else too right
like that's really all i want it's
pretty much every day's beautiful
flowers and a coffee and a cookie
[Music]